hi my name is Peter de marzo
I am the Mizzou ho Financial Group
professor of finance at the Stanford
Graduate School of Business I'm also
currently our senior associate dean for
the GSB in charge of executive education
and online programs in my research I
focus on how firms fund themselves the
types of securities that they issue and
how they market those securities also
the types of information the type of
information that firms disclose to
markets and when they choose to disclose
that information so broad aspects of
corporate finance more generally and
looking at funding decisions of firms
make
so there are number of really exciting
questions in this area currently in the
market in the wake of the financial
crisis for example one of the big
outstanding questions is understanding
the optimal funding structure for banks
one of the reasons the financial crisis
was as severe as it is is because banks
use primarily debt financing and so when
their profits drop many of the banks
find themselves underwater and unable to
continue doubt government support and so
one of the main topics of my research
now is looking at optimal regulation of
bank capital in particular you know
should they use as much debt funding as
they do or should we have requirements
for for banks to reduce leverage making
the financial system much less fragile
going forward
I received my PhD in economics here at
Stanford University and after that when
to teach the Kellogg Graduate School of
Management and then the Haas School of
Business at UC Berkeley
I've also the opportunity to engage in
many different executive programs as
well as numerous consulting arrangements
with firms here in Silicon Valley
being here at Stanford is a wonderful
privilege I'm delighted with the
colleagues first-rate scholars both here
in the business school but really across
the entire campus and the opportunity to
work with people from so many different
disciplines is unparalleled second is
for the outstanding quality of our
students teaching at the GSB is a real
pleasure every time I walk into the
classroom I'm always the one learning
something in addition to the students I
hope
when I think about innovation I really
think about individuals creating value
that is identifying new opportunities
ways to take resources and deploy them
in new ways but ultimately create value
both for themselves for their firms for
their customers and that's really I
think the heart of innovation